ah non
c'est le ive de gène bin1 l'édition
l'allée couverte qui nous a donné l'idée
de consacrer à bernard tapie notre
premier destroy mensuel tapis mythe des
années 80 titres jeanne et quelles
limites
fini les 70 sa balle et baba l'époque
alors et augagneur vivent les meilleurs
exit les hippies ou elle comme les youpi
bravo tapis oublier manufrance oublier
car assistance désormais tapie est au
sommet l'un faire des châteaux de
l'ex-empereur bokassa n'est pas entré
dans l'histoire dieu a créé l'homme pour
monter des entreprises l'avenir
appartient à tapis et à tous ceux qui
écoutent ses conseils maintenant les
vainqueurs aux études de marché pour
présenter pour 60 % de ce marché
je veux vraiment ça doit sûrement figure
on ne peut plus concevoir la musique
l'abordage d'un vendeur de chez vous
sans sentir il est le représentant de la
firme qui est leader dans son match
tapie aime sa femme mais il épouse sa
famille terraillon der marino madame
grès et s'agrandit pour supprimer les
pauvres c'est tout le monde soit riche
1985 sauve qui peut c'est à pie qui
chante en trois mois les emplois premier
aux chômeurs sont divisés par cinq
tapie est il vraiment bernard
est votre position par rapport à tous
les gens qui vivent rita piste un
aventurier style dallas où tous les
coups sont bons ça m'aide beaucoup mais
si tous les coups étaient bons depuis le
temps qu'on essaie de les trouver on les
aurait déjà trouvé le coin tard yann
ottavien quelle opposition par rapport à
tout ce qui vous conteste en disant
tapis c'est un aventurier à la dallas
pour tous les moyens sont permis et
c'est ce qui me conteste med
en fait ils mettent parce qu'une bonne
savoir communiquer c'est bien savoir
quoi dire c'est mieux sinon on se prend
les pieds dans le tapis
s'il y avait des choses contestable
depuis le temps qu'on fait du bruit
autour c'est tout les clochettes sonne
ça se saurait monsieur nous on va se
battre joue pas en fait les gens hors
locarno et jonny cocker notre structure
par le soutien avec moi andrew hier afin
de prendre tf1 concernant ambitions tf1
c'est l'apothéose mais la fin de la
montée c'est aussi le début de la
descente et la trop vouloir se montrer
ont fini par me pouvoir plus rien cacher
et derrière un seul grand cinoche et et
ça me voilà on est vrai
mais qu'ils ont créé
et pas seulement mais comparable et pas
seulement des trucs
question look les problèmes avec la
famille ben el cata ça la fout mal
il est trop tard tapie dit dans la pub
qu'il marche à la vendeur mais vendeurs
avec tapis ça marche pas si bien que ça
tf1 bien sûr ça peut rapporter gros mais
tapis vert ne possède qu 1,66 % du
capital dur de jouer dans la cour des
grands pas facile d'être invité au bal
du gouverneur faute d'épouser sa série
tapis décide d'enlever la ville après le
tapis rouge je suis un cas le bilan
cause c'est le carton jaune bodmer à
mort l'arbitré lui dit txeroki avait pas
vu la même photo je vous jure il a
répondu bah si moi je suis sûr d'avoir
raison
une image depuis une tendre président
qui saute sur un autre mais non mais
j'ai pas sauté je vous jure que le jour
où je vais sauter sur l'arbitrage serait
que j'aurai les plombs ont sauté moi
même et puis je le ferai et j'espère se
succéder à gastounet c'était le pari de
l'homme de faire passer des valeurs en
bourse au retour des valeurs
c'était son ambition pour les années 90
mais 88 élections législatives dans la
cité phocéenne comme on dit au ballon
faute de dévorer tout cru l'ogre le pen
dans la huitième
le manager de bernard hinault devra se
contenter de jouer les poulidor dans la
sixième n'est pas michael jackson qui
veut mon pote
l entrée c'est d'ordre c'est dur et
d'orge c'est dur en fait je pense que
c'est bien qu'on soit tous là je pense
que c'est un bon signe
là je sais quoi je ne sais pas faire ce
qu'il sait faire
je suis pas sûr qu'ils sachent faire ce
que se ferment oculaire manque de pot
tapis prend encore un record de retard
dans sa traversée de l'atlantique et il
ne barre pas mieux le phocéa que la
route à l'extrême droite
mais le vrai drame de tapis yeux c'est
de ne pas avoir été tapie y faute d'être
une rock star il aura tout fait pour
être une vedette même gagné des
milliards
pour être un artiste est tombé pile sur
le playback mon pote décidément t'es pas
vraiment synchrone nerfs